[Music]
if you want to change lives
and particularly if you want to change
organizations and if you want to change
the world you need power
so they're really a couple of major
categories of sources of power
one is kind of personal qualities which
you can develop and the second category
what i would
i would say would be structural sources
of power like where your position is
and the resources you're able to acquire
there are certainly things that you can
do to create
situations that will gain you power
so one source of power is your network
of personal relationships and your
position in that network
many people spend too much time on their
technical aspects of their job and not
enough time
managing their boss and managing the
relationships
that permit them to get things done in
order to get things done
you need the collaboration and
cooperation of other people
that requires oftentimes building
relationships with those people
so the first word of advice is spend
sufficient time the second word of
advice
is become central in your network so the
information flows through you
which gives you control and influence
the third
piece of a networking advice is to
understand
that we tend to spend most of our time
with our friends and close associates
but our friends and family and close
associates tend to know the same things
and the same people we do
which is why the most useful ties are
weak ties
people who provide you non-redundant
information and contacts
people lose power because they become
overconfident
and because they essentially stopped
doing the things that got them into
power in the first place
my colleague deborah grunfeld and along
with some co-authors have read the book
about how power leads to disinhibition
and behavior
it leads to people being not as polite
to other people as they might be so
forgetting that they have a boss
or bosses need to keep your boss happy
and the quickest way to get in trouble
with your boss
is to disagree with them even if you're
the ceo there's a board of directors
that you need to pay attention to
and you need to continually flatter them
and cultivate them so people lose power
for that reason
people lose power because maintaining
power is exhausting
if you do a good job and you don't get
on anybody's radar you may be fine
but you're not going to become powerful
in order to
hire you in order to promote you the
first thing i need to do is i have to
know about you
it's just like business strategy you
have to differentiate yourself
i mean if you bring out now a laptop
that looks like every other laptop
what is your competitive advantage there
is none you have to be noticed you need
to be vivid you need to be
differentiated
if you think about it what makes people
miserable in life
judgment judgment is this is the source
of all
unhappiness so people should stop being
so judgmental
and be more curious why is it that
airlines can succeed
even though they provide for the most
part hideous customer service
and don't fly on time and if you think
about that you'll come up with the
answer which of course
is that we have given up enforcing the
antitrust laws and so airlines don't
have to compete on service
because there's essentially no
alternatives and you know you can ask
that question in general about many
different situations
why is it that this person who i think
is completely incompetent
is more succeeding in their career than
i am and instead of saying oh this is
unfair this is horrible it's awful
learn from them what are they doing that
you're not doing
and that will then make you more
successful so we need to become more
clinical
and less judgmental
i'm asking people to be as
businesses are strategic
to be thoughtful about what are you
trying to achieve
and what are you going to need to do to
achieve it who do you need on your side
how are you going to get them on your
side what resources do you need
what network position would be useful to
you so it's neither
being moral or being immoral it is being
thoughtful and strategic about influence
and understanding the science of human
behavior
the world is hierarchical the animal
kingdom is hierarchical certainly
organization's hierarchical there's only
one dean there's only one president
there's only one ceo for the most part
and
it's better to be on the top than at the
bottom the higher you go
the narrower the hierarchy and so there
is inevitably
an invariably competition for
advancement and if there's going to be
competition for advancement
you would rather be a winner than a
loser and my job is to teach you how to
win
you have to if you have technical skills
without influence skills you're not
going to go anywhere because you can't
get anything done
if you have influence skills without
technical skills you may go places but
you'll get the wrong things done
so you really need both power and
influence
can permit you to change lives change
organizations change the world
according to the research by sir michael
marmot and others
famous british epidemiologist power to
the extent
that it is translated into job control
actually is associated with better
health and longer life
because most people experience the
absence of control is stressful
and stress is bad for your health seek
power as if your life depends upon it
because it does
you